I have some thing simultaneously fast,
fascinating and very, very scary for you.
We've covered before when Donald Trump's blue
brain seems to glitch these moments where
he simultaneously gets confused about what
he's saying, radically changes topic.
But at the same time has this visible physical
Twitch.
It happens in his shoulders.
This happened a few times now, and it happened
yesterday during Donald Trump's rally in Wildwood,
New Jersey.
But with an added quirk this time, you could
actually hear what sounds like a Fox news
host on a hot mic, unable to control their
laughter about what Donald Trump is doing.
And then immediately Fox news jumps in and
cuts away from the rally when Donald Trump's
brain appears to glitch that big a brain of
his, as he likes to say, check it out.
You'll hear Trump do that neurologically questionable
stutter and shake and change topic.
And then you'll hear a laugh and then you'll
hear Fox news jump in.
Democrats decided to shield and shelter crim.
Look, look, wait.
You have criminals.
All right.
A Washington president here in Wildwood, New
Jersey.
I just wanna get a quick comment before we
toss it over to Tucker, Molly Hemingway.
So let's watch and listen to it one more time.
Trump's ranting about Democrats and crime
or something.
The brain glitch happens.
It sounds like a, an old cassette tape melting
almost.
Um, and then you hear a Fox news host laugh
and then they cut away immediately from it.
Democrats decided to, she'll add shelter,
crim, look, look, wait.
You have criminals.
All right.
A Washington president here in Wildwood, New
Jersey.
I just want to get a quick comment before
we toss it over to Tucker.
Molly Hemingway.
It seems that even at Fox news they are realizing
that this is not normal.
Remember another recent instance of this while
Trump was speaking to the right wing group,
uh, turning points USA.
This happened
and let me begin by wishing you a beautiful
egg.
Look here.
Remember this?
You remember they were trying to take Christmas.
It's almost as if you imagine a vinyl record
is playing on a term turntable and someone
walks up to it and just sort of spins it and
you hear some scratching and then it picks
up on another spot.
Like they just move the turntable and then
there's a, you're, you're at another point
in the song, so to speak.
If you go to google.com right now as of this
morning anyway, and you type in untreated
syphilis, you will now see a picture of Donald
Trump when you Google untreated syphilis.
This is of course the work of internet trolls
who have made that happen.
But that is a phrase that is increasingly
being mentioned of back to Fox news.
Cutting away from this, remember that the
network now cutting away from Donald Trump's
brain glitches is very much of a contrast
given that they were signal boosting.
Hillary Clinton has Parkinson's type stories.
Back in 2015 and 2016 I heard this morning
from a neurologist who asked not to be identified
who said this to him, looks like some kind
of frontotemporal dementia.
Now that's an umbrella term.
It's an umbrella term for a group of conditions
that start to cause nerve loss in the brain's
frontal lobes and it tends to get worse over
time.
Um, sometimes it worsens roughly at the rate
that we're seeing it, at least publicly with
Donald Trump.
And the neurologist who wrote to me said,
if this continues, it will be very difficult
for Donald Trump to coherently debate whoever
is the democratic nominee in August or September
or whenever the debates are in the fall, he
would likely be more impaired by then.
Also certain medications like antidepressants,
often SSR eyes, they can be used in the short
term to stave off some of the symptoms of
this type of decline.
Again, we are just speculating.
I uh, and, and that is all that neurologists
and mental health professionals are able to
do because Donald Trump will not actually
subject himself to a proper screening, uh,
for what it is that is going on here.
So yet again, one of those very strange what
[inaudible] some, some are calling it a neurological
glitch, some are calling it of colloquially
a brain short circuit.
It's unusual.
It's odd.
Trump looks visibly confused and physically
shakes when it happens.
It's a question Mark and we're all just trying
to figure
it out.